[Music]
that's insane don't believe the hype
kendall Jenner and Anwar Hadid are just
having fun after the pair was spotted
kissing early Tuesday morning a source
tells ET the 22 year old model and Gigi
Hadid 18 year old brother are nothing
serious quote both of them recently got
out of relationships and don't want
anything too serious as for the elephant
in the room Kendall being best friends
with Anwar sisters Gigi and Bella the
source added that there's actually no
awkwardness quote Kendall would never
want to do anything to put her
relationship with Anwar sisters in
jeopardy Kendall and Anwar have known
each other for years and have always
been flirtatious and this is just
another sign of that but to enjoy one
another's company and things could
change but for now it's nothing serious
[Music]
Anwar isn't the only guy Kendall's been
linked to recently last week rumors
swirled that Kendall and NBA star Ben
Simmons were heating up our source says
their quote casually dating the 22 year
old Keeping Up with the Kardashians star
has always been very private about her
love life here's what she told et it's
not always easy but I don't know I just
kind of I like to keep my private life
pretty private so I try my best but at
the same time I don't I don't like to
let being seen out in public with
someone like affect my everyday life
like if I want to go grab a smoothie
with a friend who's a male I'm not gonna
like let the paparazzi like stop me from
doing that and living my life and just
being a normal person
[Music]
[Applause]